Look how much progress we've made. We've already filled up half of these values.
We're learning a lot about the motion of this object.
In fact, we already talked about how the time over here is the same over here.
There's only one time in the problem.
I can fill that in here, and I've already told you that acceleration is only straight down.
If I drop an object, it doesn't spontaneously drift to the left or right.
It goes straight down, meaning the acceleration in the x direction is 0.
Now, can you, using only the numbers in this left-hand column and these equations
fill in these remaining two entries?
Enter your answers here and here.